UTORRENT:
Once upon a time,
uTorrent was basically synonymous with torrents.
It was the go to place to download movies, music,
games, or something a bit more mature. Fun
fact, it was actually owned by Spotify in
the early days who bought the company to learn
about their peer to peer distribution system.
Spotify would end up selling off uTorrent as they
wanted to disassociate from the world of piracy
but this didn’t stop uTorrent from exploding
in popularity anyway. Till just 3 years ago,
they held nearly 70% market share within the
torrenting world with second place coming in
at just a tenth of the market share at 6.6%.
The funny part is that 2nd place, BitTorrent,
is actually the creator of BitTorrents
but they never held a candle against the
popularity of uTorrent which at their peak
translated to over a 150 million users. But,
while uTorrent still controls a dominating share
of the market, the overall pie has not just
shrunk but it has become a sliver. Take Google
Trends for example. The search interest around
uTorrent has basically been non existent for the
past 7 years with current interest standing at
just 3% of its former peak. uTorrent has very
much trying to fight this trend. For instance,
they launched a web version of uTorrent a couple
of years ago. And while that did reach a 1 million
daily active users, it’s nothing in comparison to
the glory days. uTorrent is very much feeling the
pain and at this point, it seems like they’re
just fighting for survival. They’ve stuffed in
ads into their UI and introduced paid tiers in
hopes of keeping the effort worthwhile. But,
with interest in uTorrent continuing to dwindle,
this seems like an increasingly uphill battle.
That’s why when uTorrent temporarily went down
in early 2023, many speculated if that was the
end of uTorrent altogether. Fortunately
for uTorrent and its remaining users,
this wasn’t the case but it did give a glimpse
into the inevitable future. But, what happened?
How did everyone forget about a once ubiquitous
service with over a hundred million users? Well,
join me as we take a look back at the monumental
rise and fall of the king of torrents.
AN UNEXPECTED SUCCESS:
uTorrent very much popularized the idea of
downloading files in a decentralized manner. And
companies are currently popularizing the idea of
raising money in a decentralized manner with the
help of bonds. If you’re not familiar with bonds,
it’s essentially way for governments and companies
to raise money from the general public as well as
other companies and financial institutions.
These companies and governments will then
turn around and use this money to fund expansion
efforts, research and development, and growth. And
in return for helping them, they’ll pay you back
with interest rates of currently 4-7%. Investors
like Warren Buffett are currently buying bonds
hand over first and locking in historically high
interest rates for the long term. If you’d like to
do the same thing with the safety of $500,000 in
SIPC insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance,
please consider checking out our bond investing
app, Silo, in the description below. But anyway,
getting back to uTorrent, the story of uTorrent
takes us back to the early 2000s to a Swedish
programmer named Ludvig Strigeus. Ludvig never
had any aspirations of creating something
massive or being in the spotlight. He was
just a programmer who liked solving issues
that he came across on a day to day basis,
and uTorrent was one of these creations. You see,
Ludvig was involved within the torrenting space in
the early 2000s and he couldn’t stand that most
bittorrents came along with a bunch of bloatware
and were resource hogs. So, in 2004, he started
working on a no frills bittorrent in his free
time. This was very much an on and off thing. In
fact, after working on it for just a month, Ludvig
would lose interest and sideline the project for
nearly a year. But, he did eventually come back to
it in September of 2005 with a new vigor. In fact,
he would finish off the program in just 3 days and
launch uTorrent on September 18, 2005. Speaking
of the name, if you look closely at the logo,
you’ll see that the first letter isn’t exactly a
u. Personally, when I was a kid, I always thought
that this was just a stylized cursive u but
this is actually a greek letter called mu. In
the computing world, mu usually refers to micro,
so you could pronounce uTorrent as muTorrent or
microTorrent and this is actually the case in
many countries. If this is true your country,
comment down below where you’re from. But,
for most users, including Ludvig himself,
the mu looked like a u and thus it became known
as uTorrent. Within just a few months of launch,
hundreds of thousands of people would end up
downloading the client, and Ludvig would continue
working on uTorrent. For example, uTorrent would
become one of the first clients to implement DHT
support and BitTorrent encryption. But, while
these were nice additions, the main factor that
sold uTorrent was its light weight design. This
didn’t just catch the eye of pirates through,
it also caught the eye of Daniel Ek, the future
CEO of Spotify. Back in 2005 though, Daniel was
just another Swedish programmer who was fascinated
by the innerworkings of uTorrent and especially
Ludvig. You see, Daniel had already begun working
on Spotify and they were figuring out the hard way
that pursuing a server client model for streaming
music woud be extraordinarily expensive. So,
instead, they wanted to leverage a light weight
peer to peer model and who better to help
them with this than Ludwig. With that, Spotify
would purchase uTorrent for an undisclosed amount
which was likely less than a million dollars.
This means that Spotify’s CEO was technically
also uTorrent’s CEO at one point in time but this
didn’t last all that long. As Spotify’s CTO put
it, “we bought uTorrent, but what we really wanted
was Ludvig.” As such, as soon as they were able to
convince Ludvig to stick around at Spotify,
they would turn around and sell uTorrent to
BitTorrent behind closed doors. It wasn’t till
years later that it would be revealed that the
sellers were actually Spotify. This was basically
the end of Ludvig’s involvement with uTorrent and
looking back, this was a great decision as
Ludvig would end up with a $100 million when
Spotify IPOed. But, while Ludvig had already
moved on, uTorrent was just getting started.
REACHING THE MOON:
While Ludvig was no longer involved,
the truth was that uTorrent had been turned
over to someone even more capable: Bram Cohen.
If you’re not familiar with Bram, he is the
father of torrenting as he created the world’s
first peer 2 peer BitTorrent based file sharing
program. He aptly named the program BitTorrent but
while BitTorrent was the OG, Bram could see that
uTorrent was OP. It was faster, more efficient,
and had a better UI, but most importantly,
it was rapidly growing in popularity. So,
armed with VC funding, Bram would take the plunge
with uTorrent but not everyone was happy. You see,
Bram didn’t exactly create torrents with piracy
in mind. Obviously, he knew that it woud happen,
but his main goal with torrents wasn’t to enable
piracy, it was to make torrents a mainstream way
to download pretty much anything. And as such, it
was important that Bram was on the right side of
the law. So, in late 2005, he would go ahead and
strike a deal with the MPAA or the Motion Picture
Association of America. This deal entailed that
Bram would remove all copyrighted material from
the official BitTorrent search engine. This turned
a lot of the torrenting community against Bram
as much of the torrenting community was also
pro piracy. Moreover, much of the torrenting
community was in favor of a decentralized network.
By purchasing uTorrent though, Bram was basically
monopolizing the torrenting space. So, the core
torrenting community wasn’t happy with any of
this but as for the general public, well, they
really didn’t care or even know about any of
this. As far as they were concerned, uTorrent
was by far the best BitTorrent client and Bram
was simply making it more stable and accessible.
Also, about Bram taking down copyrighted torrents,
well this simply made way for the Pirate Bay,
Kick Ass Torrents, and a slew of other search
engines for torrents leading us into the glory
days of uTorrent. By 2008, uTorrent boasted
over 25 million active users and it was basically
synonymous with torrents but there was one major
problem: money. All of this was funded using
investor capital meaning that sooner or later,
investors would want to see a return. This
was very much a tricky line to walk as doing
anything over the top would simply push away
users and make way for a new BitTorrent. So,
the company started off simple. They would
start bundling in optional toolbars into their
installations. They would also add in a Google
powered torrent search. These actually brought in
a pretty decent amount of revenue, an estimated
$15 to $20 million per year. But with a 125
million users to support and the 2008 financial
recession, it simply wasn’t enough. In fact,
BitTorrent would be forced to do layoffs and close
parts of their business. But despite the losses,
BitTorrent was able to scrap by mostly thanks to
just how stupidly popular uTorrent was. Investors
weren’t gonna just let a platform with over
a hundred million active users go under just
because of a funding issue. So, they helped keep
BitTorrent afloat but see, this only works as long
as uTorrent is growing at an unprecedented
rate which we know wouldn’t last forever.
THE UNGRACEFUL FALL:
The truth is that much
of uTorrent’s fall from grace wasn’t even their
fault. The reality is that interest in torrents
has simply fallen substantially over the past
decade thanks to more affordable legal options
entering the market. Ironically, one of these
options is of course Spotify which has largely
made music piracy a thing of the past. So, by
helping Spotify succeed, Ludvig actually ended
up killing his original invention which is quite
poetic actually but Spotify was just one factor.
This same trend occurred in basically every
copyrighted industry. You no longer had to be
$40 to $60 per month just to watch TV shows and
with a bunch of ads. Instead, you could just pay
$10 per month to Netflix and get access to a
far larger library whenever you want. The same
thing could be said about gaming as well. Many of
the most popular games of the 2010s whether it’s
Clash of Clans or Fortnite were completely free
to play. They made their money based on in game
purchases making it useless to pirate these games.
Also, as for the games that were still paid,
well, a lot of these were dependent on online
functionality which you couldn’t really get if
you pirated. And as for software, well most
software just became free as they learned to
monetize our use as opposed to our purchase.
Just as all of this was starting to unfold,
some of the biggest piracy sites would be taken
down. This included Megaupload in 2012 and the
Pirate Bay in 2014. Of course, replacements
would pop up to take their place but these
never reached the same scale because people simply
didn’t feel the need for these services. I mean,
just take a look at this graph showcasing the
interest around downloading free movies. And as
piracy began to lose steam, it was only natural
that uTorrent followed suit making them more and
more desperate. First, they would add ads in
late 2012. Then, they would add a pro tier for
$20 per year which kind of nerfed the free tier.
These changes definitely made the free version of
uTorrent less appealing but these changes were
understandable. At the end of the day uTorrent
was a business that needed to make money. But,
a change that the community would not tolerate,
however, was deception. In early 2015, uTorrent
would begin secretly installing a cryptocurrency
miner onto user’s computers in order to mine
litecoin and generate more revenue. Not only
was this bloatware but it was rather shady
given that uTorrent was very much trying to
do it under the radar. And with that, uTorrent
had officially been around long enough to see
themselves become the villain and this pretty much
sealed the fate for uTorrent. The core torrenting
community would move onto other services like
qBitTorrent while the general public would
ditch torrenting altogether leading us into
uTorrent’s current situation. For years now,
BitTorrent has been shutting down service after
service after service, so uTorrent may very well
be on the chopping block next. The financials
of uTorrent aren’t public, so it’s difficult to
judge the financial viability of uTorrent. Maybe
uTorrent is breakeven or even slightly making a
profit, it’s not clear. But, what is clear is
that the glory days of uTorrent are long behind
us and all we have left is a shell of their
formerselves. Someone else that went through
a similar journey is the Pirate Bay. If you’d like
to hear about their story, check out this video.